so remember that youth this is the
YouTube viral it's not the best game
this is the most viral success thing
right Ken do you want to go first okay
but first all right are you ready hey
first game might be I think it's gonna
be as just hold on to your seats cuz
it's gonna blow you straight at em if
you don't
it's called Netflix and kill yeah it's a
dating simulator of course you know you
have to uh it's kind of a murder mystery
dating kind of thing where you gotta go
on dates gotta figure people out and
then you gotta figure out which guy our
girl you want to take over to the house
and Netflix and chill with and not die
so if you don't go with them you kill
that me no no not if you picked the
wrong one and your Netflix and chilling
they're gonna be Netflix and killing
your ass alright you're out of time that
was that was great Ken
thinking you started off well but crying
let me tell you if you want a real game
to invest in let me let me tell you a
real game so you're taller trying to get
to survive against other toddlers on an
island because all your parents left you
there because you're a piece of [ __ ]
toddler
this is [ __ ] annoying then and then
the ones who survive then gets to level
up you know if you if you survive your
level off to adults and the adults get
to choose between the bad and the good
college that gets to go to fight on the
island and if you level up from an adult
you become Hitler and it's called
toddler simulator 2020 beautiful all
right what's the verdict right bro gonna
be toddler simulated twenty or Netflix
and killer that's what's the next
YouTube viral I think I'm gonna have to
go with Netflix and kill for twenty
dollars
baby I'm sorry it just runs off so well
of that Netflix in the show thing people
really like to do cuz everyone likes to
have next game you go ahead okay the
next game I got I got several games
we're gonna see which ones I like the
most to see okay this game is called
cowboy butts dropping me nuts
oh boy books trophy notes all right
here's what's your game
but I can't not beating that title good
capital e bus dropped me nuts it's a
game about a pair of Wranglers who've
had enough
leaving the ranch and dreams of becoming
skinny jeans on the hipster I think I'm
thinking are like RPG style right now
yes it was like a really awkward
knockoff of my brave little poster
that's gonna be hard to beat I'm gonna
have to pull out my guess so all right
well skinny jeans no one really likes
that I mean I do
okay so Pokemon everyone wants Pokemon
to be real right sure the problem is
it's not ethical right right I mean if
you think about it yeah I guess maybe
not really we've all had a dead okay
like where this is going please continue
so I'm bringing you the same idea of in
the same idea at Mecca maan mirco more
oh you basically take your animal and
texted erm - it I guess you say you put
it in a machine and you make them fight
each other make a mind [ __ ] it would be
who would be Team Rocket like Peter or
something that's mean Peter Hunger Games
thing okay that's my idea points good
can you get 50 bucks
no.11 you gave me okay let's ship it
real life there are there are great game
maker games but I think that kind of
game would Excel better in a 3d
environment alright well that was great
Congrats Kenya I guess you're the real
winner I mean you have five bucks